quand j'étais petit moins mon rêve
c'était de guy lafleur
peut-être qu'il ya un certain qu'ils
connaissent pas disons que c'est votre
sidney crosby à vous jeter un petit peu
plus vieux et je me voyais dans le
dernier match de coupe stanley le
septième match en quatrième période de
prolongation conti le but et le les
spectateurs guie guie guie puis moins de
vie la coupe stanley dit waouh j'avais
un beau rêve puis moment donné ma mère à
montreux suisse règles on dit pourquoi
tu serais pas toi-même guy lafleur il
existe des jo tu peux pas il affleure
alors j'ai décidé d'être moment de
tracer mon chemin et c'est un petit plus
que je vous j'essaye de vous lancer
comme défi aujourd'hui c'est à partir
d'aujourd'hui faisait un premier pas
pour tracer votre propre chemin dans la
vie prendre vos propres décisions et
aller de l'avant avec ça et je vous
dirais que mes racines de sports
extrêmes ont commencé en même temps j'ai
appris que il venait de mon père mon
père son sport extrême c'est d'amener la
famille au complet tout seul en france
le problème c'est qu'à 29 enfants avec
lui et ma mère ses deux ailes ce que je
retiens c'est son intelligence à
dissoudre reste la maison fodé keita
enseignes du 10e enfants aussi mais là
on est parti en france et à cette époque
l'une des français parce qu'ici en
amérique du nord
on vivait avec des indiens à plumes et
des cowboys à cheval des rues alors
quand on est arrivés en france ont leur
jouer un petit tour on est installé
notre tante qui était un tipi indien
ça a été un super voyage pour mes onze
ans et je pourrais vous dire qu'à ce
moment lorsque mes parents savaient pas
ce qu'ils venaient de m'ouvrir une porte
sur le monde
je savais que je peux aller découvrir la
planète à partir de ce moment là et
finalement les vrais ses rentrées sur
mon parcours
quand j'ai rencontré cet homme babu un
et palais que du record guinness
il a passé 21 heures au sommet de
l'everest sans oxygène en moyens ne
grimpe à repasser 10 15 minutes
ils sont notre corps il essayait en 2000
pendant que j'étais en expédition avec
lui il voulait partir du camp de base de
l'everest jusqu'au sommet le plus
rapidement possible et lorsqu'on est sur
l'everest le premier mois de salaire à
s'acclimater ont fait le yoyo en
cliquant par duke un camp de on revient
on commence on fait ça pour aller
chercher plus de globules rouges et
qu'on est prêt pour le sommet on ne le
feu vert d'un but au camp de base moins
choquant 4 et on pense le ce mais en
même temps babu qui courent il sera
aucun d'eux il prend le temps de manger
il se met des vêtements chauds moi je
t'ai ans montait à partir du cap vert le
sommaire aps un bout par duke 1 2
continue mon aucun iii montrent aucun 4
ils mangent encore les mêmes beaucoup
mangé faut le dire
et là moi je continue à monter et
tranquillement durant la nuit une tape
dans le dos ça va bien et abriel
il ne fait toi kilomètres je trouverais
300 m
j'en revenais pas et sur soi lui et son
frère ont été les seuls à gravir
l'everest
il fait son record qui tient toujours
16h56
moi j'ai pas réussi le sommet que vous
voyez des vrais ce parce que dans vie
j'avais tout réussi les autres se mais
je les avais réussi et celle là ça a été
un échec parce que j'avais pour familles
devront pour moi ça allait être facile
et je me suis frappé un mur j'ai passé
près de la mort deux nuits
aucun d'eux 6500 mètres mon sac de
couchage a fait défaut faisait moins 25
l'hypothermie
je suis redescendu quand même vivant
mais je savais qu'un jour j'allais
revenir sur l'everest
et vous savez babou ses sauts mais là
ils les faisaient pour une cause
il y attirer l'attention des médias
parce que dans son pays les jeunes qui
vont à l'école
il marche une heure pour aller à l'école
et match d'une heure pour revenir à la
maison le soir alors réussi sa mission à
faire construire des écoles
malheureusement l'année suivante babu
est décédé dans une crevasse
mais babou m'avait laissé une leçon très
importante
gabriel situé au sommet de l'everest
pour impressionner les gens tu fait
fausse route si tu vas au sommet d'une
personne qui t'attend avec une médaille
ya pas dix mille personnes qui sont là
tu attends date applaudir il faut qu'ils
trouvent une mission dans la vie est un
moment donné j'étais à la maison j'étais
en train de lire que le président des
états unis john f kennedy avait demandé
aux américains de se rassembler dans une
mission ali m un homme sur la lune et je
me suis dit faut je trouve ma mission et
john f kennedy italiens la nasa visite
surprise et demande un concierge qu'est
ce que tu fais toi comme travail et le
concierge dee jay z à merde
un homme sur la lune il se voyait pas
entrer une belle idée plancher vider les
poubelles il faisait partie blick calé
partir en mission et c'est ce qu'il
fallait que je trouve
puis ma mission je les trouvais c'est
aider les gens depuis que je suis petit
j'ai réglé dans les gens en les causes
sociales que je fais j'ai même des gens
sur la montagne et un moment donné un
jeune père de famille graphique du quart
cinq petits garçons qui me demandent de
l'amener au sommet du mont blanc n'est
pas grimpeur je sais pourquoi je
t'emmènerai et là il dit parce que juste
sensibiliser les gens au don d'organes
je veux que les gens signent leur carte
ici une personne qui s'installe car ma
mission sera accomplie alors qu'ils
étaient comme babou y avait une mission
g ii c'est bon on y va on a fait le
sommet du mont-blanc ensemble ma plus
belle expérience humaine en montagne on
y re venu 10 millions de canadiens ont
été touchés par notre expédition
beaucoup de signatures de dons d'organes
lui le cardiologue qui était sur notre
expédition changer des choses dans les
hôpitaux il ya plus de dons d'organes
maintenant au québec et au canada et en
2005 je faisais la même chose partait
avec cet homme schengen qui voulait être
le canadien le plus âgé a gravi le
sommet de l'everest 63 ans shining et h
en lui faisant la promotion chez les
jeunes de la santé et d'exercice
physique
il me raconte un moment donné à tous les
jours d'halloween il est sur son perron
ils épluchent des carottes puis met ça
dans un bac ses enfants via la maison
afin de l'école denis-papin
on mangera pas des carottes et des
bonbons halal wing hockey contient une
puce et carottes à 6 heures quand les
petits monstres et sorcières commencé à
sonner aux portes yutani les bonbons
mais la beauté de la chose c'est
lendemain matin shawn sorti dehors et
ramasser les petits bouts de carotte qui
traînait sur le terrain il y avait
réussi sa mission de faire manger au
moins eu légumes dans journée à un jeune
et il y en a plusieurs que manger des
carottes
alors j'en étais contente
malheureusement shain est décédée sur
l'everest en 2005 pendant je faisais
l'expédition un arrêt du coeur ses
enfants m'ont demandé d'apporter ses
cendres au sommet de l'everest
alors j'avais une mission et jetteront
pas j'étais prêt pour l'ascension du
sommet on retraverse le glacier khumbu
et ses fameuses échelle crevasse on
monte aucun deux camps 3 ou de la 3e
journée ou tôt qu'un 4 on arrive en fin
d'après midi
et l'on parle le soir parce qu'on veut
être au sommet de l'everest ou lever du
soleil et il est autour de 5h30 le matin
le soleil se lève on n'est pas encore au
sommet mais vous voyez comment les vrais
ce présentement clanche son ombre sur
les hautes montagnes
c'est de toute beauté est long on arc on
regarde et on admire et tranquillement
on voit le soleil se levait partout
autour de nous on voit le chemin qu'on a
gravi durant la nuit et on voit les gens
qui s'en viennent tranquillement sur le
même chemin qui viennent nous rejoindre
et l'on étouffe ce monsieur il reste 100
m verticale pour le sommet de l'everest
100 m verticale il fait beau tout va
bien il nous reste un endroit technique
a passé le fameux ressources ilari ilari
système c'est le passage clé que les
deux premiers hommes qui ont gravi
l'everest sur edmund hillary et tenzing
norgay ont réussi à trouver pour se
rendre au sommet de l'everest c'est un
mur de roche d'environ 13 14 mètres de
haut et on y revient avec les cordes et
d'un côté vous avez la vue
sur 2000 mètres de vide vers le côté de
chinois et de 3000 mètres sur le côté du
népal parce que vous êtes à la frontière
du tibet et du népal et tranquillement
une fois qu'on n'a pas assez ce mur là
il nous reste seulement 50 m pour
atteindre le sommet de l'everest le plut
aucun obstacle au sirop vers le sommet
et la joie au sommeil un sherpa qui est
là et qui est une radio et d'être une
personne qui arrive au sommet idiot
quand base la personne qui est arrivé
mais ce que des tranchées que dans
l'autre main d'une cigarette et moins
j'avance à un repas 8 respiration 1.8
respiration avec un masque à oxygène
d'en face incroyable et tranquillement
j'arrive près de lui et là je l'entends
dire ps kempinski m gabriel schmitt et
là où vous êtes le plus heureux au monde
vous venez d'arriver au sommet de
l'everest sur le toit du monde et comme
vous voyez on voit rien il ya trop de
monde on est chanceux dans mes lunettes
on voit un petit peu la montée mais il
ya trop de monde pour prendre une belle
photo c'est là que j'ai dit à ma
conjointe de fait je retourne l'année
prochaine c'est pourquoi j'ai été cinq
fois sur l'everest et lâche tout sommet
mais ma vraie mission d'aider à l'espace
et j'avais un foulard n'est pas laid on
appelle un kata qu'avaient les cendres
de mon amie shine à une extrémité qu'à
l'autre extrémité
j'avais le riz bénie par le dalaï lama
pour moi et je l'accroché y avait un
tripode chinoise l'accroché là c'est là
que j'ai compris qu'en bas vous m'avez
dit et lève toi plus au club reste avec
cette mission là j'étais plus au club
reste
vous savez aujourd'hui je continue à me
promener je suis tourné vers le futur
comme vous je continue à explorer le
mans je continue à aider c'est ma
mission est aujourd'hui
je vous dirai à l'explorer le mans
tracez votre propre chemin aller
chercher toutes les médailles olympiques
que vous voulez aller chercher toutes
les coupes stanley voulait tous les
diplômes que vous voulez mais ayez une
mission qui va vous amener plus haut que
l'everest
merci beaucoup